what I'm going to do is I'm going to
describe how religion can be a source of
conflict then describe how religion can
be part of the answer conceptually then
part of the answer practically and the
practical example I will give us in
relation to the Middle East peace
process which I'll talk a little bit
about and then I'm also going to say why
I think this issue is even more
important today under the impact of
globalization so that's that's that's
how I'm gonna break up my rope my
remarks you know we don't have a thought
it's not there's no blackboard but it is
it's something I can draw on I'm really
bad drawer instantly so get a laugh out
of this
well done well done
hey practical people after all you know
I'm drawn to little later in this right
plainly and obviously religion can be a
source of conflict of course so can
politics which is my answer to friends
mine who say you know religions the
source of all the problems in the world
there say in the 20th century actually
most people died as a result of
extremist political ideology but one of
the curious things is that as Miroslav
was just saying of course there is very
seldom on a causal effect of religion so
if you take northern island or the
Middle East peace process you talk
what's happening in about what's
happening in Nigeria today even if you
go back actually and look at things like
the Crusades fact centuries ago plainly
religion is not the only reason there
are political economic and social forces
at work however it is in my view both
bizarre and misleading to exclude the
role of religion is at least part of the
causal Nexus for for the conflicts that
we examine and one of the things I use
frequently to say to people in Northern
Ireland when they would say to me look
it's not really about religion at all
this conflict and I would say well it's
a pity because the people engaged in
that think that it is and you know the
fact is that they are engaged in what
they're engaged in as a result of a
belief that their religion separates
them out in an exclusive way from others
and those others are a threat as a
result of that feeling if you take a
dispute like the Mindanao dispute in the
Philippines I mean you can put all sorts
of territorial and political issues into
the mix but actually to leave aside
religion altogether would be a
misunderstanding of the conflict now
religion can play this dividing role
one because if it's worn as a badge of
identity in opposition to others it can
divide people too
because a religious Duty is a higher
form of duty
the flipside of that being a good thing
is that it can also be a transcendently
bad thing because it's ordering you for
example in the name of God to go and
kill someone and thirdly it can be a
source of conflict because people
believe that the only way to protect the
exclusivity of their religion is by
eliminating the other so religion has
this powerful effect and people do
identify in this pathway I remember the
most interesting things about Northern
Ireland and stomach I said this to you
before but when I was doing the peace
process in the course of long
discussions during the night you know
occasionally just sit around and talk to
people about the issue and they you know
I would just ask them to explain things
so one of the things I once asked a
group of Protestants to explain is how
can you tell if they're Catholic because
what they'd often do is they just come
across a young guy in the street and
beaten to death okay now they're all
weave why occasion or do you say this is
a matter of interest I mean I know it's
wrong but how could you tell and they
would say you can always tell and the
absolutely weird thing is that they
would be right in some way some some egg
given off and actually if you talk to
some people about sunni-shia they can
also do the same they can do the same
thing so religion can be this source of
conflict because it can divide people by
identity because
it can lay claim to a higher power
ordering you to do the violence and
because it's a method of protecting that
identity but I would argue religion can
at least conceptually be part of the
answer to it could be part of the answer
because one exactly what Miroslav was
saying about the concept of forgiveness
and actually buddy talks about in
relation to Croatia is a very powerful
personal example of that because really
what forgiveness is about and you could
see this in the the information we gave
you about the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission in South Africa forgiveness
as Marissa was rightly saying you see
beyond the concept of justice I mean it
move you on beyond the idea that it's
just about what's fair because what's
fair maybe the total condemnation of the
other side but the concept of
forgiveness that's very deep within
religion can move you to a different
position which says even despite that
nonetheless it's my duty to reconcile
one of the most remarkable things about
the Northern Ireland process is was the
setting up of a charity by a man called
Colin Perry whose child had died in a in
an IRA bomb that was planted in the
middle of the northwest of England and
he's I think his job was 10 or 11 at the
time and was killed one of the most
difficult things I ever had to do as a
prime minister was when you sat with
victims of the violence in Northern
Ireland and their families when I was
sitting down with the IRA to talk about
peace and these people would say to me
you are sitting and shaking the hand
of the people that killed my son my
daughter my my wife my husband and you
know how can you do such a thing ha how
can you sit there with it and this man
Colin Perry actually founded an
organization that was all about
reconciliation where he actually went
out and he met and eventually he
actually met the people who were
responsible for the death of his child
and was prepared to reconcile with them
and that is that is something that is
only imaginable if you've moved beyond
what is fair or what is just as
something that is that is deeper and
look as we say all the way through some
of these impulses can come from people
who are not the slightest bit religious
but nonetheless there's also as I've
said a more modest claim we make which
is that these impulses can derive from
religion religion can provide secondly a
very strong impetus to justice to the
concept of justice itself you know there
are Israelis who will work passionately
in the cause of a Palestinian state
Israeli organizations Jewish
organizations that will do so that will
disagree for example strongly with the
current Israeli government and will do
so often motivated by concepts from
their own religious faith which impel
them towards the notion of
reconciliation there's another idea
about this as well which i think is
important is that religion and religious
values can be a a discipline to on
people because of the concept in the
sense of just rewards for your behavior
you know so however much you may be
forgiven nonetheless there is a sense to
in which
if you behave very badly towards other
human beings there is some some concept
of retribution of a divine nature at
least just this morning I was reading
the passage in the in the Bible where
King King David falls in love with
Bathsheba who is the wife of Uriah the
Hittite and sends you either hid out
into the front line of battle to get him
killed so that he can so that he can be
with Uriah's wife and this is wonderful
passage where Nathan the Prophet then
ghost King David and explains to him
what a wicked thing this is to have done
and he says to him the Lord gave you
everything you know he gave you these
kingdoms to rule these these cities to
govern he gave you untold riches he gave
you all this happiness and you repay him
with this act of treachery and malice
and then David is because in the you
know a period of penance and so on for
what he has done but the point is that
religious faith I think in Herenton
in our religious faith is a concept that
even if this world does not make you pay
for the sins that you've committed that
nonetheless there is some concept of
divine justice that that that alters the
scales and is the discipline on us in
the behavior that we we have so religion
gives the sense of justice not just in
the sense of it a just cause but also in
the sense of a just retribution for
behavior that is wrong religion and
religious faith thirdly has conceptually
very strongly within it the idea of not
passing by that is there in the
Christian religions very powerfully
there in in in Islam one of the earliest
dictates
of the Lord to these Israelites was to
treat the Sedona or the the the person
that stayed with you fairly and well and
that idea of not passing by is very very
powerful within religious doctrine and
that that then for example when it came
to the conflict in Sierra Leone a few
years back not million the intervention
my country did not ever help Sierra
Leone but also within Syria in itself
when the country was being torn apart if
you've seen the film Blood Diamond Union
you know what the dispute was was over
and how there was a time when the
democracy was about to be taken over by
a sort of gangster group that was run by
various interests that wanted to take
the country's resources and actually one
powerful factor in a country that's
fifty percent Christian fifty percent
Muslim was the activities of those
religious leaders who said that even if
we were apart from this conflict in some
way cuz it was happening between various
elements of various villages we had an
obligation to intervene because we could
not pass by and then fourthly religion
conceptually can be part of the answer
because the very thing that Miroslav was
talking about earlier
religious faith puts a claim above the
claim of government national race really
religious faith as it is is a a claim of
duty to humanity in the name of God that
transcends the claims that your
government may make on you to do
something or your nation and if you ever
get the chance to read the story of
Dietrich Bonhoeffer and and his time in
Nazi Germany and you can see in his life
and in his teaching was this incredibly
powerful
or assault that he made on the notion
that any form of patriotism could demand
that you did such evil in the name of
your nation and actually the political
ideology of the 21st of the 20th century
that did so much damage were precisely
in a way and ideologies that demanded
obedience to nation or to idiot illy
ology over and above religious faith a
fascinating account is is the account of
Nazi Germany's relationship with the the
church which in some aspects and with
parts of the church is very shameful for
the church but on the other hand with
those that took a different view and
actually protested their point of
protest was that we have a higher duty
than anything that you can ask us to Oh
to the nation-state to the fatherland
and the reason why in the end Nazi
Germany insidee ology was inconsistent
with with obedience to religious face
words precisely because the whole point
about the ideology was that this
racially pure concept of the fatherland
came before any notion of religious
obedience so religion I would say
conceptually
and can do this can play a role and be a
force for reconciliation but I would
also say religion could be part of the
answer practically as as as well and
this is where I will if we've got yeah I
do this specifically in relation to the
Middle East peace process just talk a
little bit about backs you might find it
kind of interesting anyway and basically
the point that I want to make here is
that when you're leading a negotiation
in very
very difficult circumstances actually at
certain key points it isn't simply about
political interests some of the deadlock
can only be unbroken by values and some
of those values are actually religiously
based and religiously grounded
especially in circumstances where
religion plays a part now I'm a really
bad first time I did this it looked
completely obscene so I want a damn
anyway
that really is bad isn't it no it's
alright okay that she is a lot smaller
than that this is really really bad
right if you take the whole of the
region in the Middle East right it
doesn't really look like that but
actually it actually doesn't look like
that at all but except in one sense its
depth in one sense you see the scale of
the region and this is sort of Israel
and Palestine in there so it's a tiny
tiny bit of land which is then
surrounded by very large countries large
in population or large in in landmass
right then when you come here which is
basically this writ large
here is the West Bank this would be Gaza
here the state of right so it should be
a little bit smaller and you were and
his his basically where Jerusalem will
be right around like there okay now what
actually happens in this situation I
mean that is probably the worst drawing
of the middle-east map you'll ever see
but what actually happens in this
situation is that you've got two things
that are going on the first is that the
actual territory of Israel and Palestine
is tiny compared with the whole of the
region and what that means is
essentially is that people in Israel
feel that they are living in actually a
very small bit of land surrounded by
essentially nations that are of
different culture a different religion
and are at the moment or to varying
degrees in a vehicle or hostile to them
and then when you come to the actual
situation in Israel Palestine what you
find is that you've got the West Bank
this is probably about I don't know from
here to here but I don't know 15 20
maybe less actually at points it goes
right into about ten kilometers between
the West Bank and the coast and there
you have Gaza
down here it is therefore absolutely
inconceivable and impossible since you
got settlers in this part of the West
Bank - and you've got 20% of the Israeli
population that are Arab in this part of
the world it is absolutely impossible to
conceive of peace except on the basis of
reconciliation at a profound level in
other words what people always say is
though this is a matter of territory
right the Palestinians who are
predominately Muslim they get this bit
in this bit and the Israelis that are
predominantly Jewish they get that bit
there actually because when you look at
it it's in this this tiny bit of land in
this vast area it is completely
unconcerned conceivable that these two
can make peace together simply on the
basis of a territorial deal I mean the
reason why it's so hard to make peace in
this context and in my judgment why we
haven't so far is because it isn't just
a matter of what is the appropriate
territory or what are the borders
actually the borders people can pretty
much work out you can do land swaps for
some parts of the settlements
you've got the 1967 Green Line it's not
actually that hard
except that if the Israelis can't be
sure of security and the Palestinians
can't be sure of sovereignty then
actually it doesn't matter what they
agree in concept about the territory or
the borders there's not going to be
peace so the reconciliation that you
have to have is absolutely fundamental
to the peace it's fundamental because
the territory is so small it's
fundamental incidentally for a very
plain and obvious reason which is
Jerusalem you know which is divided into
East and West Jerusalem and the holy
city which is very small in in geography
very small but is the holy place for all
of the Abrahamic religions
you can't resolve this by leaving aside
religion and religious faith if there
are people who believe as a result of
their religion that they should have the
exclusive right to worship there you're
not going to get peace
so in Jerusalem itself this concept of
reconciliation is absolutely vital
politically actually this Arab world
that surrounds Israel here is today like
Israel probably as worried about the
influence of the power up here which is
Iran as they are about the existence of
the State of Israel on the Arab side or
the Arab hostility on the Israeli side
now they actually have a combined
interest today can combine strategic
interest in making sure that power of
Iran is properly curtailed it's very
hard for them to come to that view
without accepting the fact that just
because you're a Jew doesn't mean to say
that you don't have the same right to
exist in this region as me as a as a
Muslim because if they are going to have
a point of unity strategically against
what is a sheer Muslim power then that
can only really happen if they're
prepared to put their strategic
interests before their religious
difference and of course the very reason
why Iran operates very strongly with the
people in Gaza is precisely in order to
make sure that that should not happen
that that they see a common enemy in
Israel rather than the Israelis linking
up with the Arabs and seeing a common
common enemy in the power of Iran but
the principal reason why the reality is
so important is that without some
concept of peaceful coexistence and
reconciliation it is impossible for
Israel
to believe that it is going to have
security in this small territory large
area small territory
absolutely mixed living side-by-side and
likewise for the Palestinians it will be
impossible to think that the Israelis
are ever going to really in no
circumstance and let them run their
territory especially as they will have
to join this territory up across Israel
unless there is some concept of
fundamental reconciliation between not
just the two peoples but actually the
two cultures so this is when you look at
religion in this context yes you can see
it as the source of the conflict in some
respects at any rate partially at any
rate but it's also the concept of
reconciliation in a religious sense is
also a fundamental part of the solution
because otherwise the politics is always
going to be hobbled by an essential
belief on the part of both peoples that
they are irredeemably divided according
to culture and religion and then the
geography which is the reason for my
appalling Maps then make it extremely
hard to then reach a political solution
so sometimes when people say to you now
look the problem is you know you just
need to get the parties in a room and
work out a deal and and so on actually
that is not going to produce an
agreement unless it is matched by the
development on the ground of sufficient
points of Rickon reconciliation and
working together and living together
there makes sense of that concept of
territorial division and of course the
whole idea really of the two-state
solution because there never has been a
Palestinian state and before the
nineteen end of the 1940s there had
been an Israeli state the whole concept
of the two-state solution and peace is
the granting of a state run for the
Palestinian people one for the Israeli
people on the basis not just of fair
distribution of territory which itself
is difficult but in fact resolvable but
on the basis that it is possible for two
peoples in that small space in that
large region to live together peacefully
so that concept of peace isn't just
about practical political negotiation it
is also about practical religious
reconciliation and about people learning
to treat each other as equals in as
partners an idea that itself is not
possible if you regard the other the
person different from you as essentially
inferior or hostile so that's why of
course religion is in part responsible
for this but it is also in part the
solution to it and that's why when we
examine this issue to do with religion
and reconciliation and people say look
religion is the problem in fact because
so many people are motivated by their
faith and because faith is a real living
reality of these two peoples in the
lives that they lead it is inconceivable
to talk about a peace process that
doesn't have within it this concept also
of reconciliation in a religious sense
so I therefore think region can be a
source of conflict it can conceptually
be part of the answer in terms of its
value systems and the claims that it
lays it can also practically be part of
the answer
by bringing about the context within
which political negotiation to resolve
conflict can succeed and why finally is
this even more relevant today in the era
of globalization it might be one because
as I've said before in globalization
people are pushed together second and
this is a very interesting point about
the way the world works today because of
modern communication images of conflict
are immediately transmitted across the
world so if something bad happens in
down in abroad throughout are there that
bad image doesn't stay there for more
than 20 minutes it will be and the next
day certainly will be up on websites and
transmitted right across the globe so
why is this more relevant today in the
era of globalization is because
globalization is not just about pushing
people together it's also about visual
impact that modern technology allows in
events that happen how things are
disseminated both provocatively and
emotionally as well as rationally it has
relevance thirdly because human capital
is how the world succeeds today and
human capital cannot be developed except
within a framework of reconciliation
rather than conflict so
my conclusion from from this is as
follows that in today's world this
concept of read religious reconciliation
is more important than ever before
because of the way globalization impacts
on our world that it is true that
religion and religious conflict is a
major problem and possibly the majority
of conflicts in the world today have a
religious dimension to them but it is
also true that both conceptually and
practically reconciliation through the
force of religious ideas and religious
practice can play a part in resolving
conflict and in bringing about peace and
harmony and this comes back eventually
of course to the fundamental question
that lies behind the whole reason for
creating the foundation the course and
everything else which is this what is
necessary then to ensure that religion
plays the positive not the negative role
and the answer is to have a view of
religion that is anti exclusivist and
that is open to those of a different
faith
so let's take about 10 minute break and
then we'll reconvene and cut straight
strangers you people actually taking
down what you say very dangerous I would
have thought but yeah
you